[Music]
cardio late night
[Music]
I'm back in the big brown from now on
don't even call me a B this Tommy
picture yeah
Antonia brown from earlier this week as
he was trying his damndest to get a
commitment from the Steelers that they
were tried to trade him one of the
ugliest divorces unfolding before our
eyes right now even though there's a
chance there may not be a divorce Chris
that inspired the idea for today's pft
live draft the ugliest divorces in NFL
history as always you call tails coin
toss is rigged and then we go for no I'm
gonna go heads today cuz I think now's
the day that she's gonna give you heads
Kristen so you have self
I really have Kristen I just didn't
realize you liked me so much sorry
dammit dammit you want me to pick first
you don't seem like you're ready no I am
ready I just assumed you were gonna win
the coin toss assumed you were gonna
call test I'm gonna start with what I
think was far uglier in hindsight than
any divorce we've ever seen in the NFL
to the point where the guy who was at
the center of it I don't think ever went
back to the city involved and that was
the divorce between Art Modell and
Cleveland Wow he moved the Browns in
1995 the people went nuts they spurned
Modell and I know for a long time he
couldn't go back I don't think he ever
went back in his lifetime stats take a
look into that as to whether he ever
went back to Cleveland after 1995 but
that tore the Browns fan base upside
down and fortunately there was enough
leverage exercised there to get a
commitment that there would be number
one the Browns name left behind and
number two the Browns would return to
the NFL four years later so it worked
out in the end although the team that
left the team that left ended up being
pretty good over the last 23 years a lot
better than the Browns have been yeah
definitely that's a good one I didn't
think about that one so I give you a lot
of credit there but that certainly was a
yes I should have held it until around
three would have I would have never
guessed that one I really wouldn't I've
been thinking player and coach really
all together but that is one of the
ugliest NFL divorces I mean I still
remember that I can remember my dad
going to sign with the Cleveland Browns
and there last year in Cleveland with
Bill Belichick as the head coach
we got the Jersey still that he was
gonna hold up with the press conference
but they couldn't pay him what they
promised to pay him cuz they were going
broke they're in Cleveland and they had
to move to Baltimore and that was ugly
and disturbing and everything so that's
a good one I give you that I think the
one I'm gonna go with is Joe Montana in
the San Francisco 49ers I mean it's
pretty rare when you see a divorce
between a four-time Super Bowl winning
quarterback who had won three Super Bowl
MVPs at the time kind of be shoved out
of town when he still had playing years
left in front of them and we know he had
playing years left in front of him
because he went to Kansas City and
brought them to the playoffs and brought
them to the AFC Championship Game one
year so that to me just growing up Joe
Montana was the Tom Brady of that era
where he was the ultimate franchise
quarterback winner clutch had all the
hardware to prove it and the 49ers were
pushing him out the door for Steve Young
at the time and it was just rare and
weird to see Joe Montana sitting on the
bench and just sitting there holding a
clipboard watching Steve Young but then
of course he got his chance to go to
Kansas City and and it ended strong
there I can't remember where I heard
this story but I heard it somewhere that
I believe it may have been straight from
Montana on a TV show but there was a
time when both he and Steve Young were
in San Francisco and they were trying to
have you know an actual friendly and
collegial relationship and Steve Young
came to dinner at joe Montana's house
and one of his kids said dad is this the
guy we hate shaving cream in his cleats
in Green Bay I don't know whether or not
any of Brett Favre's kids put shaving
cream and Aaron Rodgers shoes but the
2008 divorce between Favre and the
Packers as ugly as it has ever been in
my estimation between a player and a
team and and I think that in February of
2008 the Packers knew damn well what
they were doing when they went to him
and
we need an answer now they were sick of
five years of will I or won't I
holding them hostage Chris as you would
say and they wanted an answer at a time
when they knew the answer was going to
be I retire and what they did after that
they already had Aaron Rodgers they
drafted two other quarterbacks that year
at the equivalent of barricading the
door with furniture so Favre couldn't
come back and then it started to rumble
in July Favre is figured I'll come back
I remember he was on with David
Letterman right around the draft when he
was on the cover of Madden and he said
well you never know when you never know
what's gonna happen when football season
comes and the next thing you know he
tried to force his way back in he did
show up he forced them to trade him it
was an ugly contentious mess and
eventually he ended up a year later
after a season with the Jets with the
Minnesota Vikings all because he wanted
to try to stick it to the Packers as
best he could that to me even uglier
than Montana leaving the 49 yeah it is I
know I couldn't figure which one I
wanted to go with their first I went
with Montana just because I guess he won
four Super Bowls but you're right I mean
the brett farr thing is it was ugly and
it was ugly you know the years leading
up to it right Mike I mean just you know
him every year kind of holding the team
hostage oh let me think if I'm gonna
retire I don't know what I'm gonna do
and they were kind of sitting there
waiting as free agency would unfold and
go are you plan or you're not we'd like
to know if we got a quarterback this
year and then of course they finally
drew a line in the sand and everything
changed from there so that's definitely
up there would you man would you have
taken mine if I took that one first
would you have gotten Montana next no no
that's how a better one stands yeah got
veterans you're really losing this one
today this is not even this is a
landslide already shut your mouth I
could I could not pick in round three
and still win they're so full of crap
I'm gonna go with is
one of the worst divorces I can ever
remember really I think just from pure
like dysfunctional relationship this
really might be number one and that's
Marcus Allen leaving the Oh what were
they the Los Angeles Raiders at that
time but the the bad relationship that
he had with Al Davis the owner of the
Oakland Raiders at that time that was
historic I mean come on Marcus Allen was
one of the greatest running backs in the
history of the sport
he certainly uh at that time was the
greatest running back in the history of
the Raiders organization he won a Super
Bowl MVP for them and one of the
greatest performances we ever saw as a
running back and he got in a contract
dispute with Al Davis and man Al Davis
stuck it to him hard and I know there's
always been stories there's more to the
story and that well I can only talk
about what I know and what it looked
like and it was ugly I mean to the fact
where they weren't giving Marcus Allen
the ball at the running back position of
course Bo Jackson came into the fold
they drafted him and then they may
Marcus Allen be the full-back but at the
end of the day he eventually goes to the
Kansas City Chiefs and has a phenomenal
end to his career there and stuck it to
the Raiders when all said and done
played them ten times on the Chiefs and
went nine and one against them but that
is one of the ugliest ones I can
remember Mike and I don't disagree with
that and I was impressed you thought of
that one but you know that there's a
very very ugly divorce that was as
contentious cantankerous and acrimonious
as any we've seen play out publicly the
shirtless driveway situps
the next question press conference the
full-year effort by Terrell Owens to get
out of Philadelphia eventually suspended
for four games for conduct detrimental
the team sent home with pay after that
it was so bad they changed the rules the
next year so you can't send a guy home
with pay Terrell Owens and the
Philadelphia Eagles the ugliest divorce
arguably even uglier than Brett Favre I
just want me far because it was a
quarterback position and and he ended up
playing with the Vikings but you know
tio ended up playing with the Cowboys so
it's still kind of in that same category
this is a landslide Chris you should not
even bother in round three I don't know
what you can do to redeem yourself in
this one I
have destroyed you today well but be
quiet who are you to talk you don't know
this yet okay and you picked an owner
and we're not even sure if that was
afraid for the rules can we spit it back
nope oh that's a great idea I would have
never thought of that it was a good idea
but I don't know if that was in the
rulebook for today's okay Bill Belichick
is a player you would give up two
first-round picks for I had a feeling
you're gonna bring that up okay all
right I think my last one I know there's
some ones in modern history where I want
to talk about like Bill Belichick with
the Jets that was a good one but it was
only a day I'm gonna throw out another
running back in the 80s and I'm gonna go
with Eric Dickerson in the Los Angeles
Rams okay I mean Eric Dickerson is still
the all-time single season leading
rusher leading rushing leader whatever
the hell I'm trying to say there you
know what I'm trying to say he was
really all I actually don't know I
really do he's really off and he rushed
for what still stands as the highest
mark in a single season ever in 1984
1985 he sits out a few games comes back
he's still one of the league leaders in
rushing has really a great next few
years but just this constant dispute
over money when the owners of the Rams
which ultimately gets him traded to the
Indianapolis Colts and I believe 1988 I
could be wrong if you guys fact-checked
me there but I know it's right around
that point but that was ugly and of
course I mean he was a special player
too coming out of SMU he was unlike
really any running back we had ever seen
at that time this long long striding
praying mantis with goggles and a jheri
curl coming out like it was this he was
amazing football player and it seemed
like they were never on the same page
there in LA and Dickerson and eventually
that leads to a bad breakup and hidden
playing for the Indianapolis Colts you
know we could go several more rounds on
this one let me just mention some of the
ones that didn't make the list just
refresh people's memory because there
have been plenty of ugly relationships
that fell apart for NFL teams obviously
with Antonio Brown of the Steelers
that's unfolding as we speak
you've got the Bill Belichick short-time
I on the cocktail napkin I resign as HC
of the nyj right you got
Bill Parcells leaving the Patriot that
was hanging over the Patriots the year
they lost to the Packers in the
Superbowl Bobby Petrino when he just up
and left the Falcons in his first year
as head coach and worked done who never
has a bad word to say about anybody went
public with his criticism of Petrina
that came the same year Michael Vick and
the Falcons had their falling apart Nick
Saban and the Dolphins yeah and and also
the Randy Moss second time in Minnesota
with with the the food I wouldn't feed
to my dog and Brad Brad Childress
cutting him loose after just a few games
they gave up a third-round pick for
Randy Moss they gave up more to get Moss
in 2010 than the Patriots gave up to get
Moss in 2007 and they kept him for three
games Lane Kiffin and the Raiders
remember that with the overhead
projector without Davis and one last
when Jay Cutler and the Denver Broncos
from that that was as soon as Josh
McDaniels came in he was out were you on
the Broncos then III yes I was I was
sitting out a Josh McDaniels door
waiting to have a meeting with him when
it was all going down and they told me
to go home because something was going
down and I was like wow I wonder what
this is and I turned the TV on and I
said we were trading Jay Cutler so I was
there for that how about LeSean McCoy
with the Philadelphia Eagles or DeSean
Jackson those were other ones that I
thought about those are good too all
right
plenty of things to discuss but I this
is a landslide never gonna forget this
day February 21 2019 the day that I
slammed Chris
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports